from TMZ Kid Rock and joyza Bud Light oh
so apparently uh Kid Rock was spotted at
an event at the Sky Deck in Nashville
Thursday night at Colt Ford's show
drinking Bud Light
so a lot of people are saying it's
probably the only beer they had or
whatever but uh I don't know I guess a
lot I guess the point of the story is
this is a guy who was who opened fire on
Bud Lights at Fu who now I guess doesn't
care all that much and is back on you
know drinking it I mean look I haven't
had anything I haven't had a drink in
many many many many years now like it's
like five six years or whatever so I'm
not the one to talk smack But like
after all of the stuff like right you
may you go out of the way to make a
video and stuff you'd think that he'd
have the wits about him to drink whiskey
that night it's not like it's not like
Bud light's the only option I mean maybe
it was okay fine but like dude can you
you could go a day without drinking to
not get this uh this photo I just think
that there's too much attention put on
this stuff you know like I don't drink
so I don't really care either way you
know because I'm not drinking beer
regardless but but people get so worked
up about this and I don't know I just
find these stories to be a little silly
at times because because okay yeah Dylan
Mulvaney was put on a Bud Light Bud
Light can and yeah it's not exactly
tasteful that Bud Light had an entire
marketing campaign that was trying to
force transgenderism on the public but
the obsessiveness right of of like the
right on this issue it's just I just
feel like these are distractions and
there's a lot more important issues in
our country I understand you want to you
can boycott them but the media right
they'll fixate on it they'll talk about
it but they're not talking about other
things that matter there's so many
stories that go unreported every single
day because especially the right they
have this obsessive nature and this
obsessive quality and latching on to
things and and it's like okay we get it
okay it's kind of it's kind of tired now
we can move on to other things that are
more important we can move on to sorry
also more important I think this is the
most important thing
as I've mentioned now you know 50
billion times ad nauseam to our audience
laws are only enforced if a culture
supports it so the reason why police
refuse to enforce the law against these
adult sex shows that they're inviting
children to is because television
Walmart Amazon and all their libraries
and and all the small businesses are
putting up the flag saying this is what
we want so the cops are like I know it's
illegal but we're not going to get
involved because we'll be shunned and
ostracized I understand where you're
coming from but there's just there's
just so much that's fed to
people around these topics for example
right and this is what I'm talking about
with them wasting everybody's time
everybody gets in a in a you know in a
hissy fit about Bud Light and they say
okay we're gonna we're gonna boycott and
then it's like all these viral videos of
of of popular politicians coming out
with videos like Ron DeSantis for
example right he sat down with Benny
Johnson who had his camera crew come
with Rhonda Santos and was like oh so
Governor what's your favorite beer oh I
really like a Guinness I really like
Guinness and I'm not going to drink Bud
Light anymore well yeah okay I think
that bud light's in the wrong for for
pushing transgender them on to the
public well guess what Guinness also
okay had an entire marketing campaign
where they had a had a TV commercial
marketing Guinness beer
um and it was uh a teenager at a
Christmas celebration you can even pull
up the commercial too so people can see
it type in Guinness uh transgender
commercial and it's about a grandfather
who sees right I think it's I remember
this one I think it's his grandson and I
guess the the grandfather grandfather
was like a secret cross-dresser and then
realized J and B whiskey yeah whatever
it is no but it was no but it was a
Guinness there was a Guinness there can
be a whiskey commercial no but there it
was it was for Guinness if you type it
in Guinness that actually had this issue
as well and so Ronda Santos then goes on
this whole tirade with Benny Johnson and
he says okay well I'm never gonna drink
a Bud Light ever again and then two
weeks later what does he do he has a
fundraiser in Washington DC and one of
the coast uh co-sponsors of this
fundraiser is a guy named Slater Bayless
who is one of the lobby yes for Bud
Light so just a clarification the J B
whiskey is I guess it's the parent
company for Guinness yeah
they're just not that educated if you're
going to do do a boycott on something
and you're going to take such a hard
line stance and you're going to be like
Oh I'm gonna be against Bud Light
because they're pushing transgenderism
actually you know like have the
intellectual motivation to go
investigate whether these other
companies are pushing this it's
embarrassing and it just shows you know
how it we deserve better as voters and
as the American people we deserve better
than politicians that are going to try
to win our votes by saying that they're
going to boycott Bud Light because
they're against transgenderism and then
they're going to have a closed door
slimy DC fundraiser with the lobbyists
of the manufacturer of the child
castration drugs and the manufacturers
of all these you know all these Bud
Light friends I see the I hear the left
making that same point right it's like
don't you know all these other brands do
Pride stuff and you guys you silly
conservatives are just focused on Bud
Light
I don't like that argument it's like the
the Beast is too big to stop so you
might as well just give up now right
yeah like you gotta we um
I'm saying that they need to be
principled and then they say and then
they waste all this time focusing on
these what's the point of people sitting
down with Ron DeSantis and letting him
bloviate about how okay he's against Bud
Light when they're just gonna let him
have a pass because he's having these
fundraisers and they're they're not even
they're not even morally consistent but
I don't care about Rhonda Sanders on
this issue my point that's my issue
politics is Downstream from culture if
and the left doesn't know this for years
that's why they heavily invest in
Hollywood and music it's why they ban
and like you you got this big song right
now rich men north of Richmond the
reason it's big is because regular
people have the ability to share a song
that resonates with them what do we get
from corporate mainstream media this
weird woke garbage nonsense you get Kim
Petrus and you get Sam Smith doing
Satanism on stage then you get a guy in
Appalachia singing about how how they're
screwing over the little guy and regular
people can push that make it go viral
culture is what drives political
politics if you make something
culturally unacceptable it just can't
happen and I I understand that I
understand that I understand the point
that you're trying to make but what I'm
saying is that in order it's not exactly
culturally unacceptable because they're
still engaging in it behind closed doors
yeah they lost 400. actually you
actually have to you actually have to
stick to it and we just have lazy
politicians and lazy people in our
society that say oh well you know I'm
just gonna have a closed door fundraiser
I'm going to have a Bud Light they don't
even stick with it and then we end up
having egg on her face and it's just
it's embarrassing that's why we call out
Kid Rock for hypocrisy some people are
saying it's a Pepsi can no I checked
that Pepsi cans have vertical barcodes I
look that that's a that looks like a Bud
Light can I'm gonna say I can't really
tell what that can is fine Fair Point uh
but
Bud Light has lost 400 million dollars
they've lost around 30 and has an uh
Anheuser uh uh a B inbev has lost around
30 I think their stock took a major hit
ab and Bev was forced to sell off like
eight different craft beers they have
been hit so hard by this it is it is to
the point now where you've got
corporations trying to with to pull back
from all this crazy leftist garbage
Target for instance for the first time
in six years missed their their
quarterly projections and lost money
you've got uh Disney now facing a major
backlash Netflix Disney and a bunch of
these these streaming channels lost
subscribers and it's because they keep
trying to push this insane woke leftism
yeah and I understand I I support I
support the boycotts but I think that at
the end of the day right there's too
many people who are given a free pass
right especially politicians who like to
go on Fox News and have their 36 second
talking points about these issues and
it's just something and fair point I I
mean these are the loudest people about
it but then they're doing it themselves
the politicians are grifters who are
going to be like what's popular and just
try and pretend that they're going to be
on board with it like this ad is
supporting Guinness after the fact even
though Guinness was like also and I'm
here to talk about Ron DeSantis right
which is why I brought up Rhonda Sampson
Bud Light but you know I wanted to make
people aware of that that's how you're
going to capture gen Z2 is talking about
this cultural stuff right I mean that's
what the kids care about they don't care
about the nitty-gritty and how deep
these issues go they like the funny
picture of Kid Rock holding a Bud Light
after he just posted a video a few
months earlier
young people actually care about issues
you know like there's a lot of young
people that would really like to be able
to have families and own a home and
they're finding it unaffordable right
now to own a home in America and the
only candidate that is actually talking
about uh Generation Z and Millennials
being able to have affordable homes and
be able to have affordable housing is
Donald Trump he's the only one he's the
only one who's actually talking about it
and talking about his plan for what does
he call it Freedom cities I believe
right isn't that what he calls it Tim
his freedom City so that young people in
America can also experience the American
dream I don't I don't I don't like this
idea that oh it's just young people
consumed with Tick Tock and culture
there's a lot of young people that care
about the economy that care about the
fact that by 2045 do you know that
Generation Z is the last generation in
this country that's going to be a
majority white we're not going to have a
majority White America anymore
so we what I'm saying is that we are you
know we are being
what is what is what is the race that
people have to do with
what I'm talking about is that we're
we're being replaced right so people
have talked about replacement
replacement Theory and they've talked
about the fact that we've we've been
invaded we've had uh an immigration
Invasion into our country that is
changing our culture so you're saying
that politics is Downstream from culture
but nobody seems to care about the fact
that immigration is fundamentally
transforming uh the traditional culture
of our country right so there's young
people that care about that ourselves
we've lost our culture right so the
racial component I don't see as
mattering thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time